all right we're gonna get started the
sound system in this room is not on yet
as you can tell we may get that fixed
over the course of talk we may not so if
you can't hear me just raise your hand
wave wildly and I'll project a little
more but can everyone hear me in the
back for the moment all right great
see if I can keep this up for a half
hour so I'm here today to talk about how
we can use Python and kind of open
source PI data technologies that you see
on the left here to understand what
drives NBA foul calls it's a really
interesting data set that the NBA has
been releasing for a few years that
makes this possible so what I kind of
look at this as a case study of how to
do a modern statistical workflow in
Python how can you iteratively fit
models criticize them improve your
predictions and visualize your
predictions too to kind of you know do
science in Python so it's a little bit
of a case study there I'd like to thank
first of all all of you for coming and
the PI data folks for organizing this
conference I know organizing conferences
is a ton of work no matter how much you
do it and Microsoft for hosting us in
this lovely facility this morning so
here's a little bit about me I work at a
place called mana Tate a ecommerce
technology company in Philadelphia if I
plug them briefly that we're hiring my
boss pays for these trips so uh if
you're interesting and that sort of
thing come come chat with me afterwards
most of all PI mc3 contributor grab a
pie mc3 sticker either from me or the PI
data booth at any point in this
conference there's a couple other PI MC
3 people here as well
lots of PI MC 3 talks on the docket and
then here's a list of some other places
you can find me on the internet if you
want to get in touch with me one of the
things that I really like to do is
executable slides so this talk if you
can't tell from the style is actually
generated from a Jupiter notebook as you
can see right here so you can download
this talk I have a docker file on github
that will produce a container that
contains all the dependencies and run
this talk modify it see uh see if
anything interests you change things up
so this is posted as a gist on github
I just link to these slides from my
Twitter which is just first name last
name Austin Radford so if you're
interested you can get the slides
there and then the notebook is linked to
in the slides well that's for later
Oh on the presentation yeah for sure
so we're here to analyze data from what
the MBA caused their last two minute
reports so starting I believe in the
2015-2016 season maybe the 2013-2014
season the MBA started releasing reports
that they prepare internally on their
referees performance in the last two
minutes of every game that is close
enough they don't do it for blowouts
right and this is really interesting
right because it includes both fouls
that were actually called and plays that
the NBA thought the decision was at
least in question and so it also
includes some non calls right so if you
go through a play-by-play log of NBA
data you're just gonna get calls you're
never gonna get non calls right so the
fact that this data set from the last
two minutes of most NBA games includes
non calls lets us study some interesting
phenomena in basketball that we can't
just buy just from play by place data
sets so that's what we're gonna work
with today I just want to give a shout
out because the MBA being the NBA
publishes these as PDFs not as a nice
CSV to rustle Goldenberg from oh nice
website called the pudding who built a
node application to scrape these every
day he publishes the data on github
every day was kind enough to MIT license
it when I asked him to they've done some
really interesting work in a different
direction on this data in terms of when
do referees get the calls right or not
so this not only includes this data and
not only includes if you look at it
whether or not a call was made but
whether or not the league believes the
correct call was made so they've done
some things around incorrect calls here
we're just gonna look at whether or not
the call was made
so we load our dataset up and this is
what it looks like it contains lots of
informations each column here you'll
notice I've transposed this data frame
because it's pretty wide is actually a
row of our data set corresponds to a
play in the last two minute record right
so it tells you a period it's and
they'll also include the last two
minutes of overtime if a game goes to
overtime the amount of time left in the
game the call type the players involved
in the play the review decision
CN c stands for correct non call that
means the referees didn't call a foul
and the league agreed with them right i
NC would mean incorrect non call the
referees didn't make a call when the
league thought there should be one right
gives us the team's the dates the scores
all very useful and interesting stuff so
this is the data we're gonna work with
to try to understand what factors drive
foul cause in the NBA using Python so we
want to study two research questions one
what factors of games drive foul calls
right if you if you watch basketball
you'll know certain things about game
and deuce fouls right and two is player
skill a factor in whether or not a foul
is called right are certain players
better at drawing fouls or certain
players really bad at defense and just
foul a lot right that's the question we
want to try to use this data to answer
the two questions so that's kind of what
we're going to attack today so we're
gonna start out just with a little
exploratory data analysis kind of using
pandas to plot some things we want to
look at you know all the different call
types there's lots of different call
types that the NBA includes here so
you'll see the most frequent one is
fouls right that one has happened you
know over ten thousand times in this
data set that spans roughly three years
of the NBA then turnovers instant
replays we're gonna focus on foul calls
here right we set out to study foul
calls studying instant replays and when
those are upheld in to overturn could be
another really interesting project based
off this data set it's just not one I've
attacked yet so if we drill down into
foul calls we see that there's a lot of
different kinds of foul calls right
personal fouls
just between two players but when one of
them is not shooting is the most
frequent there are over a thousand of
those right followed by shooting fouls
when someone gets hacked while they're
taking a shot there's still over a
thousand of those you see there's a lot
of fouls that go kind of on and on and
on we're gonna focus on a subset of five
of these which I believe our personal
shooting offensive loose ball and away
from the play because these are the most
likely just for simplicity to involve
two players right like a defensive
three-second penalty that only involves
a player on defense we could include
those in this analysis with a little
creativity it just complicates things
for a you know 3035 minute talk so we're
gonna leave those out for simplicity so
you can see in the notebook how data
transformation happens the lovely thing
about this talk being a notebook is that
there's tons of hidden cells you could
see all the code that's going on I have
included even lots of markdown
commentary and links to things that I
don't have time to cover in this talk
data transformation is just kind of
messy a user site can learn it's
actually not that bad but it's verbose
and doesn't make for good talk material
so we transform that raw data which I'd
player names and team names and stuff
like that into this nice little data
frame where we've you know assigned call
types IDs and we've assigned players IDs
right instead of James Harden we get
player 162 which we can go back and look
up to being James Harden so you can see
how all this happens kind of under the
cover using scikit-learn like I said
it's all in the notebook just not great
talk material not gripping talk material
so now that we have this information
what we want to do is start to attack
our research questions how does game
context influence foul calls and doop
does play your skill factor into foul
calls at all so like I said I want this
talk to be a little bit kind of a case
study of right because this isn't a
sports analytics conference this is a PI
data conference of how does Python how
does open source Python data analysis
software enable kind of what I like to
think of as a modern workflow for
statistical science and so we're going
to take this from George box spiritually
paraphrased by Dustin Tran what's a good
workflow
for statistical science so first you
should build a model of the science tell
a story about how your data was
generated right the second you use that
model to infer unknown quantities given
your data and then the third is you see
how well the predictions of that model
stack up to your data right sometimes
they're not going to stack up that well
so you build another model repeat go
back to the top right you kind of go
through these cycles and iterate so
we're going to go through this cycle
three times to get better and better
models of this MBA data that we can
eventually answer our question with our
questions excuse me can everyone still
hear me okay so let's start by building
a model of the science so what I've done
here is I've grouped each call by the
season there are only two full seasons
in this data set 2015 2016 and 2016 2017
so we're just going to restrict our
attention to the first two season to the
two full seasons that are present and I
want to look at the foul call rates
between each season we see they vary
pretty dramatically right in the first
season first full season it's above 40%
and the second full season about 30% of
plays result in foul calls right so
that's pretty different maybe let's
start by modeling that if you follow the
NBA a little bit you can guess why this
is we'll talk about that in a little bit
there's a good reason for this and why
we want to model that difference so like
I said I'm a PI mc3 developer we're
gonna use PI MC 3 here it's not a focus
of this talk we're not gonna go in depth
on what it is or what that means if
you're interested in Beijing data
analysis or PI MC 3 there's tons of
links to reference materials in the
hidden cells here that you can use to
explore that but that's not kind of the
focus of what we're gonna do so what I
said before build a model of the science
is to tell a generative story about the
data right I like to think about it as
telling the story of how the data was
created so our first story about how the
data was created is that each season has
a different foul call rate right you'll
see this normal distribution has shape
too and season here is - that's the
number of full seasons in the data and
we're just using this to do a little
logistic regression right we force it
through a sigmoid function to give the
probability that a foul is called and
then given that probability whether or
not foul is called that's just like
flipping a weighted coin right we get a
Bernoulli distribution I'm moving
through this stuff quick you can read
lots about it elsewhere so now we've
told our story about how this data was
generated which is that each season has
a different foul call rate we need to
infer the model given data right we need
to learn what those foul call rates are
right we've just said they're different
we haven't learned what they are yet
from the data so like I said we're using
pi MC 3 a package for modern Bayesian
analysis at lots of talks on pi MC 3
here or that at least touch on pi MC 3
so that's exciting I would highly
recommend going to to them later and
even a workshop on Stan I believe which
is another package that does some
similar stuff very useful but all we
need to know for this is that we sample
from something to get to perform that
inference to learn what those foul call
rates are so we've done some sampling
from a posterior distribution and that's
what counts as inference for the
purposes of this talk we want to make
sure our inference is good right we
shouldn't just trust that our algorithms
have converged so we do a little
convergence Diagnostics Andrew Gelman
who will be speaking here tomorrow has a
quote that I like which is that when you
have computational problems usually it's
a problem with your model not your
programming right so we should check
that we haven't had computational
problems because those can help us
diagnose model problems so here we see
some some Bayesian Diagnostics not that
important the nice thing here is that
the Gilman Rubin statistic which
influence which indicates convergence of
our sampling is close to one it's one
within three decimal places so we feel
pretty good about ourselves like I said
tons of reference material about this
stuff in the hidden cells of the talk if
you're interested in diving deeper on
the Bayesian theory so now we want to be
in the step of criticizing this model
given our data so how well does this
model stack up to our data when we use
it to make predictions right so we're
going to form this residual data frame
and you can see the code to do that here
but it's much simpler just to understand
what's going on
so for each play we have a 1 if a foul
was called and a 0
the foul wasn't called right and then
since we've done our inference we have a
prediction I'm calling that P hat here
right so for this first play we
predicted there's a forty point three
percent chance of foul was called same
for the second same for the third and by
now you can probably guess how we get
the residual we just subtract the two
right this is how off our prediction was
from reality right if we were really
great at predicting things we would
predict one when a foul was definitely
going to be called and zero when a foul
definitely wasn't gonna be called so
looking at those residuals is how we're
gonna criticize this model and
understand ways we can improve it
iteratively so the first thing we should
do here since we've included a between
season difference right in our model is
make sure we've captured the per season
foul call rains well so if we just take
the average residual by season we see
that it's quite small like you know I
don't know on the order of 10 to the
negative fifth so we've captured that
story of the foul call rate varies by
season fairly well right that's a very
simple story though as you can kind of
guess that's not the whole story I want
to make for a very interesting talk what
so what's one really important thing
about data science it's this you know
drew Conway Venn diagram substantive
expertise right and anyone who's watched
the last I don't know five minutes of a
MBA or college basketball game knows
that we're leaving a really important
factor out right because those last five
or 10 minutes of game time they last
freaking forever right I read some
interesting work online that like the
last two minutes of an NBA game can
often last 20 minutes and why is that
it's because of intentional fouls right
and so if you don't really if you're not
really deeply into basketball if you're
losing and you're on defense the other
team can just hold the ball and you're
not catching up right so what you can do
is intentionally foul them let them
shoot their foul shots because your team
gets the ball back so an intentional
foul is a way to force your team to get
the ball back without taking any time
off the clock which is precious when
you're losing near the end of a game
right that's kind of the general
strategy here and why these things take
so long so you know
got a piece around to take free throws
the ball a couple times you got a pace
around a little more you got a high-five
after each made free throw takes a long
time and this also gives the reason why
there's such a huge foul call difference
between those two seasons because the
NBA instituted a rule change about
intentional foul between fouls between
them here you can see Tim dunking
bear-hugging DeAndre Jordan definitely
committing an intentional foul cool fact
about DeAndre Jordan he's a horrible
foul shooter guy has like a lower than
50% success rate for foul shots when the
good players have like upwards of 80 I
probably have a 30 percent success rate
he's a professional basketball player
and he's not a lot better than me so
what would teams do they would pick the
worst player on the other team no matter
whether he had the ball or not and foul
him away from the ball because you send
him to the foul line the chance is that
the score difference goes up is really
small right well between those two
seasons the NBA instituted a rule to
change this because it became really
insufferable to watch if you committed
an intentional foul away from the ball
the other team in the last two minutes
of any period the other team not only
got to shoot their foul shots they get
the ball back not you get the ball back
so that's why that felt that's why that
intentional foul rate went way down
because intentional fouls away from the
ball on the ball still the same right an
intentional foul if you're following the
player with the ball you still get the
ball back but away from the ball you
can't just pick on DeAndre Jordan
because his team's not going to give him
the ball well actually see it's really
fun we'll see DeAndre Jordan come up
later when we talk about skill so how's
this reflected overall well we should
get more fouls as we get close to the
end of the game right that would be a
sign of intentional fouls so if we group
these residuals not by seasons but by
seconds left in the game we can see that
we're not accounting for that right our
residuals are below zero with a lot of
time left in the game meaning we're
overestimating the foul call rate with a
lot of time left and then they shoot way
up towards the end of game meaning we're
under estimating the foul call rate
right so this is some variation we need
to model we've criticized our data and
found something that we didn't model
well
so we're gonna iterate build a model
over the science take two okay so here
we just kind of do some more exploratory
data analysis to really confirm what's
going on right and we see hey when the
committing team is trailing right when
the committing team means the team who's
player would be committing the foul man
that foul that foul call rate shoots way
up near the end of the game this is like
really definitive visual evidence that
we see intentional fouls right and the
team who's leading when they're
committing they have no incentive to
foul so it stays about the same might
even go down slightly right because I
don't want to send the other team to the
line in a close game this is also
reflected in terms of the types of fouls
that get called right personal fouls get
called a ton because that's what happens
when you intentionally foul someone with
the ball while they're not shooting
right so here we see the foul call rate
for the losing team goes way up towards
the end of the game and it's very
different across the fowl types
so let's include this file type bit in
our generative story about the data nope
so we're gonna add to the fact that foul
call rates vary across season that they
vary across call types and here we're
going to use what we call a hierarchical
normal distribution again I don't have
time to really get into it but there's
tons of references I've linked to in the
in the hidden slides here so we model
that the call type base rate is
different but that's not just it right
there's there's some more subtle
behavior here if you're trailing by one
point with a minute left you're probably
not going to be intentionally fouling
right if you're trailing by five points
with a minute left you have much more
incentive to foul because you need the
ball a lot more often to make up that
difference right the larger your score
difference is the sooner you're going to
start intentionally fouling if that
makes sense so we want to model that
behavior as well so here what I've done
just as kind of evidence of that is I've
grouped these foul call rate plots into
how much the team is trailing by right
and if you think there's about three
points a basketball team can score per
possession technically you can get a
four point play but they're exceedingly
rare right so if you're trailing by one
two or three points that's one
possession you're trailing by right if
you're trailing by four or five or six
point
that's two possessions so that's how we
go from points to possessions just the
rounding down division by three okay so
we see when teams are trailing by more
possessions their incentive ties to fowl
intentionally foul much sooner that red
line is always higher than the blue line
and is usually higher than the green
line we also see this across different
file types we can see that away from
plays 'we are the personal foul is the
the absolute largest one so not only is
the base rate different but the foul
call rates change differently over time
right so this is some complex behavior
here we've identified that time is a
factor right intentional fouls are more
likely to come at the end of a game that
foul call type is a factor right and how
much you're trailing by is a factor so
we're going to end up with here is
actually a three-way interaction which
is a little bit fun so a brief interlude
to the shock clock for the NBA right a
shot clock is worked last 24 seconds if
you were to get a lead in the NBA and
there were no shot clock you just hold
the basketball forever right
shot clock means if you haven't shot by
the end of 24 seconds the other team
gets the ball automatically forces play
to go on right so the natural way to
think about time at the end of an NBA
game is not in seconds but in terms of
the number of possessions left in the
game by the shot clock right so if there
is between 0 and 24 seconds left in the
game that's one possession left right
between 25 and 48 seconds left in the
game that's two possessions left right
and more than that is three and four and
so on
so the number of possessions left in the
game is really the natural timescale for
the end of an NBA game that actually is
borne out really well in this picture
right here
so here the shading gives the rate at
which fouls are called the y-axis is how
many possessions the committing team is
losing by and the x-axis is the number
of possessions remaining in the game
you'll obviously instantly see a really
interesting pattern here right which is
that top left corner is really highly
shaded and where that top left corner
means is that your your the number of
possessions you're trailing by is more
than the number of possessions left in
the game
hey that's really intuitive it's great
to see the data bear out our intuition
on what matters in basketball this is
really cool so let's model this here you
can just see that sharp broken down by
foul types you can see that it's most
pronounced and personal but it happens
for all of them I gotta get moving a
little bit so I'm gonna kind of gloss
over this stuff so we model that
difference we include a factor that lets
the foul call rate change based on the
number of trailing possessions based on
the number of remaining possessions and
based on the call type right this is
emblematic of a three-way interaction
right so we include three-way
interactions here and we infer the model
again we look at the residuals grouped
by the possession grid we see that
they're fairly symmetric around zero
they're not too big we like this a lot
more than the other one we Bend them and
they look fine I'm not going to touch on
that that much importantly we've
captured the time behavior right now
when we group these residuals by time
they're kind of equally distributed
around zero that's nice that's what we
like to see that means we've done our
job including that pattern we do some
model selection I'm not going to touch
on this too much again tons of
information in the hidden cells lower is
better here so we see that our
possession model is way better than our
season model which I've called base so
hey we figured out how gain context
impacts foul calls Frank so check that
off I love that heat map where the top
left was all red that was super cool to
see the data line up with our intuition
when we did some feature engineering
right so now what we want to turn to is
whether or not committing or drawing
fouls is a measurable skill can we
quantify how good players are at drawing
fouls or not giving fouls when they're
on defense so what we're going to use
here
I'm gonna breeze over this a little bit
again I've included tons of reference in
the hidden cells because I'm a
mathematician at heart I can't bear to
see something not referenced out is
called an item response model why do I
have a graph of Supreme Court ideologies
over time on my screen this is the same
kind of model that people use to
reduce these Martin Quinn scores of
Supreme Court ideologies we're going to
apply that kind of mathematical model to
basketball how is that similar you can't
measure a Supreme Court justices
ideology directly right
it's a latent attribute of them that you
can infer see based on their performance
over many cases right when you see how a
judge decides on many cases you can
start to infer something about their
latent ideology here's another little
graph there all right you can infer
something about the ideology of the
cases and about the ideology of the
justices that's about as far as we're
gonna get into this but there's lots of
references in the hidden cells so to
apply this to tell a story about how our
skills might impact foul calls we say
that each disadvantage player that's the
player that's having the foul committed
on them right so DeAndre Jordan in our
picture with Tim Duncan in DeAndre
Jordan has an ideal point that's their
latent skill your ideal point means
their latent skill right and each
committing player also has a latent
skill that we're going to include in the
model and we're gonna say that the
skills impact the foul call probability
through their difference so we subtract
the disadvantage players skill DeAndre
Jordan's skill from the committing
player skill Tim Duncan's skill and that
picture I showed to see how this impacts
the foul call rate we're gonna use this
to see if we can measure player skill
there are other ways you could do it but
this is a plausible one so we still
include the game factors we just add the
game factors and the player factors
together we do our sampling and we're
going to criticize our model like I said
I'm gonna skip those pretty quickly you
can see the residuals for this model are
pretty good there in the hidden cells I
don't want to go through all those all
the time we have our first indication
here of how much skill matters irt here
stands for item response theory that's
our skill model guessing skill isn't
hugely impactful because like this is
not much better than the game factors
model right that possession model so the
fact that there's not a huge drop there
would seem to mean that skill isn't
hugely impactful here but let's go ahead
and verify that
I'm not gonna worry about this too much
I guess you could see here and this is a
bit small I apologize this plots the
posterior distribution of those skills
overall players so they kind of spread
from like negative point to at a point
to so these are not that big on the log
odds scale right so this is kind of more
confirmation that if those effects exist
they're small this is also a talk about
basketball not just about statistics so
let's tell some basketball stories for a
second so what I've plotted here is the
top 10 players and the bottom 10 players
by latent skill now this is for
disadvantaged skill this is a DeAndre
Jordan this is the people that are
having the fouls committed against them
right you see some interesting things
here Jimmy Butler is a pretty good
offensive player right you tend to think
of committing being disadvantaged
players being on offense this makes a
little sense Ricky Rubio just kind of
gets out on the court in flails I guess
that makes him get fouled a lot Tom wall
is a pretty good offensive player and
then hey we see DeAndre Jordan pop up
DeAndre Jordan so final offensive player
but man that guy gets fouled a ton
because he can't shoot foul shots right
so here we've seen out of our analysis
which is nice it builds confidence that
we're doing something reasonable that
DeAndre Jordan who we know right gets a
the hack-a-shaq strategy they called it
played against him pop up he's actually
this is for both seasons so this is the
first season for DeAndre Jordan I think
the second season of DeAndre Jordan is
like number 12 or something he just fell
outside the top 10 also really
interestingly the bottom 10 contains a
fair number of what I would consider
stars right pal Gasol I mean he's a bit
old now but that's fine he's kind of a
star Carmelo Anthony's still a pretty
big star right Kevin Durant definitely a
star Kawhi Leonard definitely a star in
the NBA right now so what's really
interesting to see these people who are
on the bottom these guys are having a
hard time getting fouls called in their
favor
right this kind of counteracts a little
bit the the narrative that maybe the NBA
is a star driven league in this sense
right if if Kevin Durant's at a
disadvantage when fouls are being
committed against him to get them
actually
called that's a little interesting we
can do the same for that committing
skill right so this is for the player
actually committing the foul right and
so we would expect on the whole this to
be the good players up here to be
indicative of good defense right because
most fouls are committed by defensive
players in the NBA and hey Danny Green
who appears here twice and each season
he's a pretty good defensive player I
think he's made the defensive team of
the NBA two or three times Gordon
Hayward I would say a pretty good
defensive player right and in the bottom
the players who aren't doing great on
defense are you know seem reasonable
also Dwight Howard at one time was
pretty good at defending the rim but I'm
pretty sure that guy is just like
checked out now right he doesn't really
play that much defense he kind of stands
there Ricky Rubio again is just a
goofball on the court
Chris Paul not known for his defensive
prowess right so it's interesting here
we can weave some basketball stories
that are latent skill model while the
differences aren't huge I mean you can
see the confidence intervals for the top
player in the bottom player are not that
separated right so this effect isn't
huge but it is producing some
interesting basketball stories at least
now it's easy to fool ourselves we could
probably tell basketball stories about
noise right so for statisticians we
should try to be a little more rigorous
if you follow sports analytics
communities a little bit how do we tell
if a latent quantity is actually a skill
we look at its year-over-year
correlation for the same player right
you should be good at this across
several seasons if you're at if it's
actually a measurable skill right so
let's take a look at that so here we
just see we have the parameters B is the
committing skill theta is the
disadvantage skill season zero and one
will jump to the good one so here we're
going to look at the year-over-year
correlation for each player and this is
for players that appeared in the data
set at least 10 times in each season
right we should have a minimum threshold
if you appeared in the first season and
not at all in the second you're not
going to be correlated and we shouldn't
expect you to and so what we're
particularly interested in is this entry
which is how B is correlated from
2015-2016 to 20
scene 20 17.3 kind of small not a huge
correlation it's not zero and I've
adopted you know the old-school
statistical Asterix here to mean the
p-value is smaller than 10 to the
negative third for what it's worth I'm
not and it's not worth that much
probably but this is significant but
small and then the theta 2 theta
correlation season over season is even
smaller and not that significant which
makes sense I would believe there's a
lot more skill and being a good defender
in the NBA than being able to draw fouls
that's that's quite Paul's with me the
conclusion here is something seems to be
there but it's small and hard to measure
is kind of what I would draw from this
how can we make it easier to measure the
NBA could release game logs these logs
which they produce I believe for each
team for all 48 minutes of the game and
not just the last two minutes we've had
to jump through a lot of Hoops here to
remove the confounding factors of
intentional fouls right if the NBA just
released all 48 minutes us from make our
job so much easier but uh this is what
it is and so yeah so we did that I have
a little demo here in my talk I said I
was gonna visualize it using - I was
pretty excited to see plotly open-source
- recently mostly because I've been
jealous of people that use are because
shiny looks so nice so I wanted
something that kind of fills the shiny
void for it for us Python East us so
here I've just put a little app really
easy kind of tutorial in the hidden
cells you can see I'm just like putting
HTML here in Python I've got some
callbacks and let's actually run this
thing so I've got this talk running as a
notebook in the background I'm actually
running a web app out of this notebook
and so hey here we got this web app so
like let's see we see this predicted
foul call probability is not that high
because we're working with away from the
play foul so let's change to personals
we should see that difference reflected
right and then let's change you know
Ricky Rubio who is pretty good at
getting fouls called in his favor and
have the defender also be Ricky Rubio
who's a bad defender
so here we can like play out
hypothetical situations to see what the
foul call rate would be all by writing
Python which is great because I am a
terrible web developer I can technically
operate Django but I'm real bad at it
so this is kind of real exciting so
we've got about five minutes left I
would like to say thank you for coming
to listen to my talk here in me yell
look quite literally yell about math and
basketball and see if there are any
questions from the audience so thanks
for your time and feel free to reach out
you know in any of these ways if you're
you have questions would like to get in
touch are curious anything yeah
[Music]
backers
[Music]
do do I the question is do I think that
the factors we've included could be
correlated with referee bias yes
definitely
the referee data in this data set is
really unreliable and spotty so that's
hard to include but yeah I would love to
be able to study that if we had a better
data set for sure I have not just
because I don't have access to that data
set if I did I would love to include it
right one of the natural extensions here
would be to include free-throw
percentage for the disadvantage player
to kind of mitigate that hack-a-shaq
effect right and that I just ran out of
time before this talk but I intend to do
in the future so you had a question over
here yeah so the question was how can we
separate you know players that are
actually good at drawing contact maybe
from players the other team is targeting
and to that what I just said
one thing you could use to reduce that
hack-a-shaq effect which is that second
one would be to include the
disadvantaged players free-throw
percentage as a mitigating factor which
I'm gonna do I'm gonna write this thing
up as a blog post at some point and I
will do that before then I just didn't
get time before now so that would be the
first step in that direction there are
probably others there was another
question yeah
[Music]
yes so what we're doing here
I can speak briefly the question was I
showed some of the Diagnostics and I
actually have those for each model I
just only showed them for the first
model again the magic of hidden cells
and notebook talks what we're doing
under the covers here is called
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo it's kind of the
workhorse of modern Bayesian inference
those energy pot right Hamiltonian comes
from physics Hamiltonians are about
energy right there are just two
different kinds of energies in this
algorithm and they should match fairly
well so these distributions shouldn't be
too different in the tails if they are
we know we've done something wrong
that's quantified in that bf mi that bf
mi tries to reduce that to a single
number that Gilman Rubin statistic if
you sample multiple chains tells you
about a cross chain versus within chain
variance and you want those to be about
the same if there's been convergence
yeah yeah so I'm I'm gonna summarize the
question as do we think we could use
this to drive better fouling strategy
the answer is yeah maybe it's not
something I've thought too much about
but I think something similar to this
could be used to build a better
data-driven fouling strategy yeah it's
exactly it's not we haven't oriented our
analysis here towards that but I and if
not exactly this analysis I think some
similar thing could be used to maybe
give a a an inspection of whether those
foul those fouling strategies are
justified by the data I think we
probably have time for one more question
and then I'll be in the hallway so if
you have more questions let me know but
then we got a call so let's go here
[Music]
you know this is mostly just kind of a
procedure I follow in Jupiter notebooks
so I don't have like great tooling for
this like I like to use Pi mc3 as you've
seen but you could use other stuff right
the stand guy so there'll be some stand
talks later have some great write-ups
about this so I mostly know about this
is kind of passed down for through
statisticians in terms of papers and
just like explanations I don't know of
any great software that kind of lets you
step through those things if that's the
question so uh yeah
in short that's the answer one more
question we had a question in the back
maybe I have a second so I I did dig
into a lot of different residuals but
not per player residuals yet there tends
to be very low sample size per player
here one thing I'm interested in getting
is men once this season is once that our
current season is a little more
progressed especially to isolate the
effect of that hack-a-shaq rule I'm
interested in revisiting this throwing
out the 2015-2016 season looking
2016-2017 versus 2017 2018 just getting
some more data getting data that doesn't
span a different hack-a-shaq era to see
what happens so it would be a good place
to go next for sure all right thanks a
lot everyone like I said I'll be hanging
out outside if you have any questions
thanks for coming
[Applause]